there's an angle to the Hillary
Clinton's health story that I've not
really discussed which many people in
our audience want me to discuss but not
necessarily for the same reason I'll
explain the the backstory is that over
the weekend what was a sort of uh
underground in a way or or catacombs
based conspiracy theory about Hillary
Clinton's health went mainstream because
of this incident she had at a 911
memorial on Sunday in New York City
where she was seen being put into a
vehicle really not under any of her own
power by a Secret Service agents or
whoever was involved there and then
speculation rage ultimately we were told
that this was a case of pneumonia that
she has that started on Friday there are
some people in our audience who have
been emailing me saying David there's
crazy crazy left wingers who were
turning a story that is objectively
about a candidate's health into a story
about sexism gender and misogyny by
saying Hillary's health is being treated
differently because she's a woman and
you have to call those people out but
there are other people who emailed me
and said David do you see what's going
on the Hillary's health story is sexist
tons of other US presidents have been
ill up before and during their
presidencies they were being attacked in
this way because when a woman feels
faint she is too weak to be President
but when a man feels faint or throws up
on another politician or whatever it is
it's no big deal so let's break this
down in pieces first of all are the
stories being told about male presidents
true will many of them are I'll put up
on the screen for you a list of some of
the incidents that are being mentioned
here medical instance incidents
involving u.s. presidents a president
franklin pierce fainted twice and did
have his testicles crushed i don't
remember anyone saying he was unfit to
be President in 1908 President Teddy
Roosevelt was blinded in his left eye
due to being punched in the face in 1919
President Woodrow Wilson had a stroke in
office in 1975 President Gerald Ford
l in Austria walking down the stairs
outside of Air Force One and actually
fell many many times and you did not see
this widespread speculation about his
fitness to be President in 1992
President George HW Bush actually
vomited and fainted during a banquet
hosted by then Japanese Prime Minister
kichi miyazawa and for many many years
Ronald Reagan showed all kinds of signs
of Alzheimer's although they were pretty
actively suppress in in many ways and
for many years of course Franklin Delano
Roosevelt had polio and was in a
wheelchair uh and you you had some
people questioning his ability to be
President but really not impacting him
in any significant way now you could
look at the list and say well David
individually none of those incidents are
the same as what is being speculated
about Hillary Clinton and the key word
there is speculated how are we comparing
what is known which is that Hillary
Clinton has fainted a few times in her
life and has pneumonia up to what is
speculated which is as someone wrote to
me yesterday Hillary Clinton has six
months to live but media speculation
even from people that are normally
pretty good has been rampant and some
examples are that on Monday NPR
commentator Cokie Roberts said that
Democrats were nervously beginning to
whisper about having Hillary Clinton
step aside didn't cite a single source
for that and hasn't sense but the same
day charlie rose from PBS ass former
president and husband of Hillary Clinton
Bill Clinton whether his wife's
pneumonia was caused by a concussion
four years ago so what's the verdict I
am comfortable saying Rachel that there
is probably some gender element to this
there is already a plethora of
stereotyping around women presidents not
able to make the strong tough decisions
with the military for example I think
that that is a slight undertone but I
also believe that objectively speaking
and maybe it's because of the modern
video age we actually have video of some
of these coughing and and and collapsing
incidents objectively speaking this
story is also a story that goes beyond
gender that that's where I'm on this I
don't
gender is irrelevant Rachel but I don't
think it is the only lens through which
we should be analyzing this gender is
definitely an element because if you're
looking at her whole kind of campaign
history there's definitely been time and
time again people saying okay she is
perceived as weak and I think the the
health narrative is kind of only
negatively contributing to that however
if you look at how McCain was covered
when he was running for president there
was report after report after report
talking about his cholesterol and his
skin cancer and there was one NBC report
that said he might die before he's
elected and yeah granted he was going to
if he was elected he would have been the
oldest president elected but I think the
issue there is uh kind of okay he's a
male she's a female they're both being
they both are covered I guess somewhat
extensively for the health but McCain
actually did release his health records
in rock which Hillary Clinton claims she
will do very very soon and we will see
when we get that so so like rachel is
saying Mitt Romney a guy who objectively
speaking did not have any issues of
specific concern in his health
background health not really an issue
even though Mitt Romney is the same age
as Hillary Clinton John McCain who is
even older than Hillary Clinton
objectively had some health concerns and
thus it was more of an issue so to the
extent that big picture Hillary has been
branded by some as weak or not tough or
whatever I think in an overall narrative
gender may be playing a role
specifically though I believe that even
if you had a 69 year old male Democratic
candidate with the exact same observable
coughing fits the fainting etcetera I
believe it would still be covered but it
might be slightly different that is
where I am on this particular issue